T Roy Eggman back on the program how are
you Troy Dan I'm good I'm good I want to
start with a quote I want you to hear
what Josh Rosen had to say yesterday
tell me what you make of this if you're
a GM and you hear this I want to know
what you would think so here's Josh
Rosen on the NFL Network with Andrew
Siciliano I've always been the number
two guy I mean coming out coming out of
high school Rickey town was the dude he
was going to SC I was going to UCLA he
was number one in the country I was
number two and he was gonna bring USC
back to the promised land
Blake Barnett he after after Rickey kind
of faded away a little break Barnett was
the elite Elite 11 MVP he was the dude
that was gonna go to Bama went a couple
championships and call it quits go to
the league's the first overall pick I
don't really you don't really hear about
him too much
Sam Donald Baker Mayfield these dudes
that are these exotic cool like flashy
quarterbacks that number one pick all
this stuff and I'm number two and you
know what I'm gonna sit here in a couple
years when all is said and done I'm I'm
confident that I'll be I'll still be
standing what do you think of that well
what I take from it Dan is a guy who
knows he's not gonna be the number one
overall pick
but knowing Josh I've known him since he
got to UCLA he's a very confident guy as
you probably know he's extremely
intelligent and I think he's this
competitive of guys there is excuse me
that's in this draft as well and and so
I I think basically what he's saying is
he's got a bit of a chip on his shoulder
doesn't like that he's not received
probably more attention than he has
going into this draft or some of the
questions about him and that when it's
all said and done he'll prove himself to
be the number one guy if I said arm
strength or accuracy which which one's
more important no down my mine accuracy
I would place that you could you could
put you could list any any quality next
accuracy and I'd go with accuracy
because you can be a great leader you
can be tough you can your teammates can
love you you can be smart you know
whatever if you can't put the ball you
know where it needs to be then none of
that other stuff matters yeah and that's
when I brought up about 15 minutes ago a
scout said look you know Josh Allen can
throw it through a wall whereas Baker
Mayfield could throw it you know add a
brick in the wall and that's what you
want
I'd much rather have accuracy than arm
strength there well I would - I put a
real premium on that and and that is the
concern of mine of Josh Allen's and and
and Lamar Jackson's those two guys and
because I think ultimately you have to
be able to put the ball where you want
to put it and as an offensive
coordinator when you go into a game and
you've gained planned a certain look to
try to take advantage of a shot down the
field and then when it finally presents
itself you've got to have the confidence
that the quarterbacks can be able to
deliver and put the ball where it needs
to be and this is a game of third downs
and we've all seen those quarterbacks
who are erratic throwing the football
and you just kind of hold your breath on
every snap as to whether or not they're
gonna be able to hit the open target so
I do understand the actuation with Josh
Allen he's a terrific talent he's a bit
of a project if you will I think he's
got have some time to develop but I
think he'll do that he's a great kid you
know the thing about it Dan is all of
these quarterbacks they have things that
you can shoot holes through and I was
talking to a general manager recently
and a former general manager and he said
that you know in his opinion if you're
gonna be a franchise quarterback there
can't be any minuses you know when you
go through the ledger everything has to
be a positive and yet with these guys
there are minuses with each and every
one of them some less than others and it
then causes you to stop and think you
know or or any of these guys actually
franchise quarterbacks and and we'll
know that in time but as we know when
you don't have a quarterback they all
look like franchise quarterbacks when
they're coming out and I think to a
certain extent we're overvaluing like we
do every year yeah I do believe that
some of these quarterbacks are being
overvalued but in an amazing though that
I think the consensus is the best player
in the draft is not going to be taken
number one and taken one Barclay right
right why well because he plays running
back and he's not a quarterback you know
I mean it's just the premium on on what
this you know I think it's always been
important to have a quarterback to win
at the
you want to win but as you know more now
the games more in the quarterbacks hands
today than it's ever been and we've seen
there just has been less importance I
guess if you will on the running back
position I'm a huge fan of say Kwan
Barclays and I agree with that statement
I think he's I think he's the best
player in the draft he's still going to
go very high but you know not where he
should go compared to the talent that he
has relative to everyone else if you ran
the Browns you would do what tomorrow
night I would take Sam darn 'old and
then I would hope say Kwan Barclay fell
to number four and I think there's a
good chance that would happen and I
think that the Browns first of all they
have to hit you know they have to hit on
the one and four but they have to hit on
one they're taking a quarterback there's
a you know there's a lot of pressure
because there's there's not a John Elway
in this draft and so I think the safest
pick and the safest pick doesn't always
mean the right pick but I think if you
look at the guy who checks the most
boxes it's Sam darn 'old I would go with
him I think there's a good chance
Berkeley falls to four I would pick him
up and I say that because I'm a guy even
though we weren't in the same draft I
went in 88
Emmett came in and a team or and I went
in 89 em attainment in 1990 and I know
what what that meant to me as a young
quarterback so I think if they were able
to hit on both those guys you know what
one in four in the same draft you know
they've got something that they could
build on for a long long time
if the Cowboys don't draft Emmitt Smith
are you in the Hall of Fame now you're
in midseason form I love that if you ran
the Giants Troy what would you do here's
what here's what I here's what I would
do and I think it's what Dave gentlemen
will do is if you believe that whoever
is left on the board knowing that the
knowing that the Browns are going to
take a quarterback if you believe anyone
who's left there's a franchise
quarterback I think you have to take
that guy and if they don't take a
quarterback then it's my below
that Dave gentleman doesn't believe that
there's a franchise quarterback on the
board or maybe there wasn't at all and
then I you know this is a this is a
league the the the difference makers in
this league are quarterbacks and pass
rushers III think then you go and you
pick up Bradley chub and unless you're
able to make a move and slide down and
maybe get a player you want and that
could happen that could happen with some
of these teams that are that are they're
a team like Buffalo for instance it has
some capital to be able to try to move
up and take a quarterback because I
think they're gonna try to make a play
at some point this didn't happen to you
I don't think in Dallas but when you see
them drafting your successor if if
you're the Saints if you're the Steelers
if you're the Chargers if you're the
Patriots
how does this affect those court if they
go first-round draft somebody's
successor here is that just part of hey
that's business and you know that I
think I think for everyone else in the
organization I understand it I mean in
some ways jimmie johnson drafted my
successor in the same year i was picked
in 89 when he drafted Steve Walsh in the
supplemental right after after I just
been chosen number one so I I think I
understand it as an organization when
you say hey we have that we have to have
a succession plan and we're in a
position now to do that but we saw it in
Denver with John Elway when they drafted
tommy maddox with the with the first
pick that was before
oh wait even won his first Superbowl I
mean he still had a lot of years left
and sought of course in Green Bay Brett
Favre did not like it no one no one
would like it because when you feel like
you still have some years left and yet
they draft the guy who you you know they
don't draft the guy in the first round
to sit on the bench for long that your
days are or maybe even more numbered
than you originally thought it's it's
not a good feeling I think it creates
some tension and I think Favre and
Rodgers would be the first to tell you
that that's what happened in Green Bay
Troy Aikman live coverage round one NFL
Draft alongside Rich Eisen from the NFL
Network mike Mayock Daniel Jeremiah and
the Stanford head football coach David
Shaw simulcast on Fox and the NFL
Network starting tomorrow night last
time you picked up a football
and through it it's but when I actually
I take that back I was on spring break
with my kids and it Cayman Islands and
one of the kids that having to run into
on the beach wanted me to throw him one
as he drove out into the ocean I quite a
while that's why I paused to think when
I last picked one up probably had been a
good four years prior to that and you
know I you know you talk about accuracy
I've always been able to put the ball
where I want it to fortunately with a
beach watching I was able to throw a
perfect ball to this kid but yeah I'm
not one who gets out and throws the ball
around if I was a head coach I would not
be Jim Harbaugh or Jason Garrett or Pete
Carroll thrown the ball around you know
in pregame warmups and I do I do
appearances with stop back right often
and I don't think star backs
ever walked by a football that he didn't
pick up and throw and and I'm not that
guy so you did hit the ocean is you know
because sometimes I say you know I the
kid wanted to be dramatic he wanted to
lay out and catch it as he was going
into the ocean no I can you know I can't
hit water falling out of a boat you know
I mean I would I would love if you were
just like this a money proposition to
Troy
you just stand on the beach like sandals
hires you and then you're just on the
beach cowboy fans a cowboy junket and
then they get one throw from Troy Aikman
you be richer than you are I don't know
how long this broadcasting gigs going to
last but when it does we would walk by
and you'd be like 70 and go what
happened to try and look at that beer
belly on Troy Aikman what happen he's
got a Super Bowl rings on though and
it's Jersey hey have fun tomorrow night
always great to catch up with you Troy
thanks for joining us that's a Troy
Aikman Cowboys Hall of Famer for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
two three
nine on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]